you ever find something on the internet
and you don't know
whether to be happy or just disappointed
cause that's how i'm feeling right now
today we're reviewing slash r found
felix
i didn't think this was real and i
didn't think it was what i thought it
was or at least i didn't think
it was what i thought it was but it's a
subreddit
dedicated to finding felix that's right
everybody we did it we hit
peak reddit everyone i'm so confused why
did i find felix
on this swedish dating site date swedish
man
hey charley can finn's in the yard
love does not eat wait the translation
of that is
love doesn't exist will date swedish man
trust in massage
would you like some trust in massage
found him in a dutch sucker club
stop this whole subreddit
is racist god [ __ ] damn it why does
everyone look like me and why has it
taken us this long to discover that
found him what the heck is this you have
not
found me you will never find me cause i
never leave my house
because i don't have legs literally this
entire sub oh that's my pul color scheme
pewds not pewds
oh i get it now found him in new york
that actually looks like me what the
hell
how does this keep happening what is
going on guys what the heck is going on
bruh i demand an answer are aliens real
pewdiepie has changed so much over the
years
why does everyone keep looking like me
smh i'm legit getting freaked out we
have christian pewdiepie
we have virgin pewdiepie we have airport
pewdiepie
we have that actually genuinely looks
like pewdiepie pewdiepie
we have football pewdiepie and we have
another that actually goddamn looks like
pewdiepie pewdiepie
why are there so many pewdiepies
this ends now i'm done with it where do
you find these pictures as well
this dude just straight up met pewds
why does that pewdiepie have my dog
pewds but five feet high
i will not stand for this cyber bullying
i am so confused
okay this is getting creepy guys i found
pewdiepie
from years ago ultra reality pewdiepie
multiverse number 55 pewdiepie
you all know it's fake because he has
legs oh okay
thank god at least we have some method
to figuring out
which is the real pewdiepie i met the
peers look alike too
same place as the other guy oh god and
even he looks alike
like the other one that the conspiracy
photo of pewds during world war indian
pewdiepie
found pewds tagged section hey look it's
high school virgin pewdiepie
great um felix is that you
i don't know it could be might as well
when you watch the news and you find
another felix lookalike
that's hilarious pardon me
it seems like i am quite quenched for
thirst is that how you say it
time for sponsor g fuel sponsor
ah you may have seen me sip on these bad
boys
for quite a while and you may be
wondering what is he actually drinking
there
is that part of some conspiracy no it's
not okay this is genuinely
great sponsor g fuel everybody i used to
be skeptical to g fuel but then brad
recommended it to me
and as soon as i tried it i was sold on
it okay i don't know about you guys but
i used to drink energy
drinks and uh i tested out g fuel i like
generally i was skeptic to it but i
found it to be a healthier solution
to just drink a g fuel instead it also
doesn't make me
uh i mean i don't know if this is true
or not but generally in my experience
when you drink it when i drink an energy
drink i get hyped for like 10 minutes
and then it goes away
but with g-fuel i genuinely don't feel
that i just feel like i get more energy
and it boosts me throughout the day
wow epic and there's so many goddamn
delicious flavors
it's funny every person that i
recommended g fuel to me has always sold
being skeptic they're like i don't know
and then they try and be like oh that's
great i just bought 50.
some of my favorite is golden apple pear
this thing is
beautiful green apple is also amazing
sour
chug rug incredible flavor i mean i hate
to say it but
in keemstar's cotton candy it's pretty
good rainbow sherbet
incredible kiwi strawberry if you check
out the link in the description
you can get my top flavors that's right
everybody
but wait enter the code pewdiepie and
you get not ten percent enough
not fifteen percent not twenty percent
percent up
thirty percent off baby add the code
pewdiepie in your checkout
and try it out see if you like it this
offer with 30
sale is only available for seven days so
do it now
i found felix back in 2013
i'm so sick of this i don't know what my
reaction to this is that's the problem
i don't know if i'm annoyed i don't know
if i'm scared
and i don't know if i'm should be
laughing or crying
time traveler felix a god damn
why are there so many [ __ ] feelings
these people didn't exist
until this subreddit existed goddamn
kazoo kid
parallel universe felix closer to the
equation
what is that old universe transgender
felix great
oh my god why are there so many world
war felix
oh god damn it that actually looks like
me i'm france now
i am of france now you know this is just
going to get worse
y'all look how many felix i found
congratulations good job
just found felix in india oh my god
that's t-series versus pewdiepie and i'm
not even there
it just re i just realized i could just
get all of these pewdiepies
and make them take over my channel and
then i don't have to be here anymore
that's great oh my god it's race car
pewdiepie race car fan pewdiepie
everybody
hey look it's way better beard pewdiepie
incredible
felix fighting a black guy i would never
by the way for the record
vox media i would never i would never
enter my hemisphere of thought
to ever do that because i would actually
die jesus christ
is that racist is that how you tell if
it's me or not if there's many
pewdiepies
then that means i can shift blame on all
my controversies
to other pewdiepies i have never done
anything bad in my entire life
this has all been old reality pewdiepies
the conspiracy
is that news media created fake
pewdiepies
to frame me innocent pie that's right
that's who i am
didn't do anything pie what the [ __ ] oh
my god jesus christ
oh my god how many more can there be
it's looking under chair pewdiepie what
the hell is that
van gogh pack why does it not stop
make it stop omnipresent being
is felix time traveler party wig
pewdiepie i'm crying
i'm actually crying virgin outside in
the snow pewdiepie
this is where it all started okay to
understand how this happened
we need to understand how it started it
started off with this goddamn
i mean god lord great lord christian
pewdiepie
oh my god it's felix blond hair and
beard
oh my god
oh my god this proves everything
there he is again traitor pewdiepie
delivers cake to t-series high quality
in india
real tradie pie he's a traitor
stop him i will not stand for this which
i can't by the way no legs can't help it
how the f does this keep happening what
if all these clones
say the n-word and kill pewds reputation
oh my god this is it this is what i've
been saying
i never made any jew jokes i never said
any bad words and i always ask myself
how did this keep happening i am 100
innocent
oh it's me pewdiepie from one day ago
how many pewdiepies are there i have
returned because i have found the source
it all started with a post from dank
memes
white people all asian look the same
also white people this is what i'm
talking about
i have found the source of this problem
and it is once again racism every day
another felix is appearing who the heck
is this guy
philosophy lecture felix that even looks
exactly like me
bros what am i doing on a train bros
all this poor pewdiepie look-alikes
everyone's snapping a photo of them
going like
this looks just like me pewdiepie into
the beauty verse
let's not go there met pewdiepie at the
victory grill
the other day great guy wow what a great
guy
oh my god it's pewdiepie in fallout 4.
it's skeety pie
poppy pie i'm cheating on marci pie
depression pie australian
okay enough go out and find the real
pewdiepie goddammit because i don't even
know if it's me
i need help also remember to check out
the g fuel promo by the way guys
30 off give it a try give it a try come
on get at least try out my favorite
flavor
ass okay guys i think it's pretty safe
to say that
uh i am the real pewdiepie no i am the
real pewdiepie no
i am the real pewdiepie that's